♪ -30 seconds to ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, Higgins, tell us what
our first challenge is.
-Well, for this first challenge,
you will have 30 seconds
to get one cookie
from the top of your forehead
all the way down to your mouth.
Only using your face. No hands.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I got this.
-Yeah.
-Oh, wait. No, no.
-First one to finish wins.
Are you guys ready?
Start at the top of
your forehead.
-Okay.
-Using your facial muscles,
get that cookie to the mouth.
30 seconds on the clock.
Ready? Set. Go!
♪♪
Okay, there you go,
he's got the nose.
Nose. Eye.
Oh, eye, eye.
Fail. Jimmy fails.
Oh, it's stuck
in the beard.
It's stuck
in the beard, oh.
Keep on going.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
It's gonna be
the eye flip, Jared.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Eye flip.
Oh!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding ding ding ding ]
-Oh!
-You are a talented --
talented individual.
That was good stuff right there.
-Oh, my gosh.
-That was unbelievable.
Can we see that in slow motion?
Is that possible?
Watch this move right here,
Jared. Watch this.
And there it comes!
And you got ya right there!
Fantastic.
30 seconds to, all right.
Oh, man!
[ Applause ]
-I can't swallow.
[ Laughter ]
-You have nothing
to drink either. All right.
[ Laughter ]
Higgins, what's next?
-Lots of gingivitis.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
You look like you just won
the Stanley Cup.
-How y'all doing?
How y'all doing?
How y'all doing out there?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How y'all doing.
-It's Jimmy Fallon!
It's Jimmy Fallon!
-Higgins, what is
our next challenge?
-Well, for this next challenge,
you'll have 30 seconds
to pull out every tissue
from a tissue box one at a time.
But you may only use one hand.
That should be easy for you,
to pull the tissues.
[ Laughter ]
So let's get 30 seconds --
30 seconds on the clock.
Get ready.
-Yep.
-Set. Pull it. Go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
20.
-Yes!
[ Ding ding ding ding ]
-We got to see that back.
[ Laughter ]
Was it Jimmy or Jared?
Hold on.
That was a photo finish.
-Wow.
-You know what that means.
-Watch this, watch it.
Ready. Oh, Jimmy!
-Fantastic right there.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I knew -- I knew
you'd be good at that.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, Higgins.
-All right.
-What is next?
That was a delicious Oreo.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the final challenge.
-All right.
-Please, gentlemen, turn around
and face the curtain.
You'll have 30 seconds to throw
as many CDs as possible
into a sliced watermelon
to get them to stick.
-Wow.
-Whoever gets the most CDs
in there wins. All right?
-All right, here we go.
-So let's get 30 seconds
on the clock.
-Yeah, you pick out
a stack.
-Ready? Set. Go.
-30 seconds.
[ Cheers and applause ]
These are all
"30 Seconds to Mars" CDs.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah! Ah! Ah.
-Been out a while now.
First studio album.
-"30 Seconds to Mars"
right now.
Whoa! Oh!
Oh! Oh, my!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, oh! Two!
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-The champ right there.
Jared Leto!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The champ.